today we're going to begin to unravel
palm what's their significance first
we'll ask when were they written and in
what language the letters of Paul are
the earliest tax written in the
Christian canon or the New Testament
they date from roughly forty nine 257
siiii and let me take a moment to
explain what I'm talking about when I
use the term Cee it sends for Common Era
BCE for before the Common Era it's the
more academic a less religiously
inflected way of talking about time
often people will say ad that means anno
domini year of our Lord or those ABC
which means before Christ as you may
know in different religions people have
different ways of dating and the term
siiii common era and BCE before the
Common Era are more academic more
neutral we know that Paul wrote more
letters than the ones contained in the
New Testament and of course we know that
communities wrote back to him but none
of those letters survived Paul's letters
were written in Greek Latin was the
primary language of those in power in
the Roman Empire and Aramaic and Hebrew
among other languages were in use among
Jews and others in the Roman province of
Judea but Greek was the common language
of the Roman Empire and we don't know if
Paul new Hebrew or Aramaic or for that
matter Latin the Greek in which the
letters of Palo written is called Koine
it's a Greek turn to talk about the
common language at the time not the more
literary or fancy versions of Greek that
imitated the stylus of the Classical
period of Greece like demosthenes our
Plato yet Paul's letters demonstrate
that he had some education in Greek and
even some knowledge of rhetoric the
third stage of education in the ancient
world